[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing wizarding transportation
not via the flu network not via
apparition and certainly not by
hippogriff
but by broomstick of course in the
muggle world a broomstick has a very
different function
but to a witch or wizard they see an
opportunity to fly
a means of getting from point a to point
b
but they're not only used in everyday
life they're also used in sport
notably quidditch without broomsticks
the game of quidditch would cease to
exist
and wouldn't that be awful brooms are
brought to the forefront of our minds
right in the beginning of the first book
film when hagrid first brings harry to
diagon alley
in complete all of everything around him
harry pauses for a moment as he walks
past
quality quidditch supplies diagonalis
premier broom shop
it's also in this moment that he
overhears other young witches and
wizards
going berserk over a broom in the window
whoa
look at it the new nimbus 2000 and from
that moment
harry was intrigued of course as the
books films progress
harry ends up getting his hands on a
couple of broomsticks though he could
have afforded the nimbus 2000
right then and there he didn't buy it
because at that stage
brooms in general were exciting to him
he didn't necessarily need
the best one however later in his first
year
in a kind but sort of questionable act
of student favoritism
minerva mcgonagall ends up sending harry
a nimbus 2000
when he becomes a part of the gryffindor
quidditch team at that time
the nimbus was the fastest broom around
capable of reaching upwards of
a hundred miles per hour but while the
nimbus 2000 was an impressive brum of
its time
it wasn't long before it was
overshadowed later being eclipsed by the
performance
of the nimbus 2001 which was even faster
however as you can guess with advancing
technology
it wasn't long before even the nimbus
2001 was eclipsed in performance
enter the fire bolt harry ripped the
parcel open and
gasped as a magnificent gleaming
broomstick rolled out
onto his bedspread ron dropped his socks
and jumped off his bed for a closer look
i don't believe it he said hoarsely it
was a firebolt identical to the
dreambroom harry had gone to sea every
day
in diagon alley its handle glittered as
he picked it up he could feel it
vibrating
and let go it hung in mid-air
unsupported
at exactly the right height for him to
mount it inside of the harry potter
books the fire bolt was the fastest
broom around
but how fast is fast as it turns out
the fire bolt was capable of achieving
speeds upwards
of 150 miles per hour or 241
kilometers per hour to put things into
real world perspective
that is 75 percent as fast as a
lamborghini gallardo
80 as fast as an apache helicopter 75
percent as fast as an average 250 gram
arrow shot from a draw bow
two times faster than a curveball in
baseball and
two times faster than a cheetah's max
sprinting speed
before the fire bolt a fast broom was
basically anything that could go
over 100 miles per hour but when the
fire bolt came out
it truly set itself apart did you guys
ever wonder just how fast proms were
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
your wizard dowry